bien rebonjour à toutes et à tous merci
d'avoir répondu présent à notre
invitation à échanger dans le cadre de
cette table ronde réserver plus
particulièrement aux architectes donc
nous recevons donc des représentants de
trois organismes le Conseil national de
l'Ordre des architectes qui représentait
par Madame Marjane et Sam far qui est
vice-présidente et Monsieur Stéphane
lutard qui est chargé de mission
transition écologique et maquette
numérique l'Ordre des architectes
comprend outre le Conseil national 17
conseils régionaux l'ordre assure
plusieurs missions de service public
comme la tenue du tableau régional des
architectes de manière à protéger et
contrôler le titre d'architecte
l'organisation de conciliation en cas de
conflit et la garantie du respect des
règles déontologiques l'ordre représente
également et promet la profession auprès
des pouvoirs publics le collège des
directeurs d'écoles d'architecture qui
représentée par Monsieur Raphaël
labrouille la Bruni président de l'école
nationale supérieure d'architecture de
Bretagne le collège rassemblés
directeurs des 20 écoles nationales
supérieures d'architecture de France
dont le statut est défini par le décret
numéro
78-266 du 8 mars
1878 et puis la Fédération nationale des
conseils d'architecture d'urbanisme et
de l'environnement qui est représenté
par sa directrice Madame Valérie
Charolais et je cite également
puisque je n'avais pas inscrit voilà
comme ça je vous présente également
merci Madame Éléonore chambra lafeuinte
vous êtes chargée de mission au sein de
la Fédération nationale des conseils
d'architecture d'urbanisme et de
l'environnement mesdames messieurs Denis
dessus alors président du Conseil
national de l'Ordre des architectes
affirmer avec force dans une tribune du
8 du 8 octobre 2020 que les architectes
sont des acteurs indispensables de la
rénovation énergétique en effet en plus
d'être à l'interlocuteur privilégié des
ménages et des acteurs du bâtiment
l'architecte doit posséder une vision
globale des enjeux du logement dont ceux
qui touchent à la transition énergétique
la formation des architectes est donc
fondamentale à ce titre la rénovation
énergétique prend une place de plus en
plus importante dans le cursus des
écoles d'architecture enfin vous allez
me dire nous le confirmer ou pas
estimez-vous que les efforts faits sont
suffisants ou qu'il faille encore aller
plus loin quant aux architectes en
exercice est-ce que les enjeux de
rénovation énergétique sont bien
intégrés au sein de la profession
avez-vous des témoignages de difficultés
rencontrées par des architectes
relatives à la réglementation et au
dispositif d'aide à la rénovation
énergétique les architectes peuvent
aussi jouer un rôle majeur
d'accompagnement des ménages et des
entreprises dès lors que pensez-vous de
la mise en œuvre de mon accompagnateur
rénov
selon vous les architectes ont est-il
été suffisamment associés à la
conception de ce dispositif enfin
l'architecte doit assurer la
conciliation entre les exigences de la
rénovation énergétique et la
préservation
architecturale du bâti comment les
spécificités des bâtiments ayant un
caractère patrimonial sont-elles prises
en compte est-ce que la réglementation à
ce sujet vous semble suffisamment
complète et précise donc je vais vous
laisser la parole pour que vous
interveniez les uns les autres dans des
propos introductifs je vous précise que
cette audition est diffusée en direct et
en différé sur le site internet du
scénario qu'un compte-rendu sera publié
je vous précise également qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende
donc je vous invite donc à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité a levé la main droite et à
dire je le jure les uns après les autres
on commence par vous madame la
vice-présidente
je te jure
voilà je vous en remercie de vous prêter
à ce formalisme mais nous devons le
respecter intrinsèquement donc on vous
laisse la parole
voilà pour le temps que vous souhaiterez
monsieur le rapporteur qui est aussi
quand même un des vôtres voilà on
portera pour votre question et puis les
membres de la commission d'enquête qui
sont ici présents à cette audition
compléteront si besoin et si toutefois
notre table ronde n'était pas achevé à
17h ne vous offusquez pas je serai
obligé de la quitter mais monsieur le
rapporteur voilà s'il doit la terminer
sera là parce que j'ai ensuite un avion
à prendre mais je pense que des heures
on aura eu le temps de bien débattre
entre nous je vous laisse la parole
peut-être à vous madame le
vice-présidente
oui bonjour
Je vous remercie pour cette invitation
quand nous sommes concertés pour voir
comment aborder ce sujet important et
centrale aujourd'hui dans nos activités
nous avons souhaité faire un rappel
effectivement de l'article 1er de la loi
du 3 janvier 77 qui déclare que
l'architecture expression de la culture
et d'intérêt public et c'est là
effectivement le
l'essence même de notre profession parce
qu'on affirmant ce principe le législat
les législateurs pardon a marqué sa
volonté de préserver promouvoir la
qualité architecturale mais également de
confier à lourde la mission de se porter
garant de cet intérêt public
en veillant à la protection des usagers
et en prenant en charge l'organisation
de la profession effectivement ce qui
est pas très connu du public mais
finalement pas beaucoup non plus des
élus c'est notre déontologie sur lequel
nous prêtons serment quand nous nous
inscrivons à l'Ordre des architectes et
cette déontologie ce qui est très
important à ce moment précis de
des décisions effectivement sur la
rénovation nous interdit effectivement
de travailler
d'être en contrat effectivement avec une
entreprise en tant qu'architecte nous
devons protéger
les intérêts de nos clients et c'est
indépendance rend intéressante la
collaboration avec un architecte qui est
là comme conseil et garant pour son
client
alors on peut rentrer un peu plus dans
le détail dans certains cas dans le
travail avec les particuliers il y a des
clauses dans les contrats où il faut
préciser qu'on connaît l'entreprise qui
intervient mais il faut toujours que le
client soit informé donc ça c'est une
information effectivement au fur et à
mesure que nous intervenons en tant
qu'élu de l'ordre
nous n'aurons nous compte que c'est une
informe informations qui n'est pas
acquise et qui fait que
le rôle de l'architecte dans la
rénovation n'est pas encore aujourd'hui
suffisamment connu ou sollicité dans ce
cadre-là pour
pas plus tard effectivement que la
semaine dernière au sein du CNH et
l'association des consommateurs étaient
présents et se plaignait des cas
multiples effectivement d'escroquerie et
dont ils étaient victimes suite à toutes
ces mesures dont on va parler par la
suite et effectivement finalement celui
qui manquait peut-être à l'appel c'était
un architecte qui pouvait être à leur
côté celui qui pouvait vérifier la
finalité de ces travaux et si c'était le
tiers de confiance voilà donc ça c'est
avant de
vous expliquer bon le Conseil de l'Ordre
vous l'avez très bien
expliqué nous sommes 17 régions et un
conseil national nous sommes tous les
élus de la part des 30000 architectes à
peu près 30 000 inscrits on se rapproche
de 39000 d'ailleurs maintenant et
notre travail c'est effectivement de
s'assurer que les architectes sont
assurés sont de bonne moralité
respectent cette déontologie et qui sont
formés donc la formation continue
voilà oui c'est le premier tout à fait
donc je parle voilà après est-ce que
vous souhaitez peut-être que je donne la
parole aux autres après je reviens sur
vos questions ok pas de souci merci
non alors madame la Directrice de la
Fédération nationale des conseils
d'architecture
ce que c'est donc
vous avez cité la loi de 77 c'est aussi
l'année de naissance des ce dans cette
même loi sur l'architecture
un conseil d'architecture d'urbanisme et
d'environnement si je devais simplifier
c'est une sorte de service public de
l'Architecture de l'Urbanisme et de
l'Environnement notre mariage et
départemental donc ça permet une
certaine proximité avec le territoire
et on a un peu de facettes une facette
où on accompagne les porteurs privés
comme public d'ailleurs de projet c'est
à dire qu'à partir du moment où il y a
une idée une intention une envie parfois
plus un projet le ce peut être là pour
accompagner et puis on a une deuxième
facette qui est un rôle de promoteur et
de diffusion de la culture
architecturale
urbaine et paysagère donc on jongle avec
ces deux facettes là et puis nous sommes
nous avons l'obligation de décliner au
niveau local les politiques publiques
nationales dont les politiques de
rénovation énergétique dont on parle là
aujourd'hui et en même temps nous avons
obligation d'écouter les besoins des
territoires
voilà qui sont sur un aménagement en
construction etc donc notre rôle par
contre est on va qualifier ça d'un rôle
amont pour ce qui est d'accompagnement
de projet c'est à dire que on est là
pour faire de l'aide à la décision pour
prenez du conseil pour expliquer faire
de la pédagogie et l'info quand même pas
mal autour de la rénovation énergétique
on y reviendra
on est là pour donner le cadre
d'intervention possible si on parle
d'architecture voilà quels sont les
types de contrats etc comment ça marche
mais on ne fait pas de maîtrise d'oeuvre
on a interdiction de faire de la
maîtrise d'oeuvre et donc un architecte
qui travaille en CAE donc qui est
conseillé architecte ne peut pas exercer
en tant qu'architecte libéral dans le
même département
pour pas qu'il y ait de conflits sauf
s'il est à temps partiel à ce moment là
et puis il y a des finitions d'un
territoire notre rôle donc sur la
question de la rénovation énergétique on
remplit ses missions là d'informations
de sensibilisation puisque nos publics
ça va être
le particulier
et à ce titre enfin au passage on trouve
un peu dommage que tous les ce nous
figurent pas dans la plateforme sur
France Renov parce qu'on touche quand
même 800 particuliers par an il faut
savoir que la principale demande le
principaut besoin des particuliers avec
lesquels nous sommes en contact ne
portent pas sur du neuf ça porte sur de
l'arabilitation donc pour nous c'est
comme aussi une piste un moment donné de
d'essayer de mobiliser tous les acteurs
dont nous ont partis évidemment mais n'a
d'autres mais sur cette plateforme là
peut-être se couper d'un réseau qui a un
maillage départemental il y a un ce
pratiquement dans tous les départements
de France
puisqu'il y en a 92 donc on a une quasi
couverture nationale
que nous avons de par la loi à
l'obligation de recevoir les
particuliers de les aiguiller etc c'est
un petit peu dommage de se couper de ce
lieu d'informations aujourd'hui cette
plateforme ne prévoit d'inscrire que les
c.e qui était espace information énergie
qui se retrouve aujourd'hui donc ça fait
16 sur 92 c'est pas suffisant je dis ça
d'autant que
évidemment tous les ce ne sont pas
équipés je dirais de la même manière en
termes de moyen humain mais par contre
on connaît très bien notre territoire et
le rôle de de ces lieux là c'est aussi
s'il n'y a pas de compétences en interne
de renvoyer vers les structures qui
existent
de renvoyer vers les procédures les
politiques publiques qui peuvent être
mises en place donc si nous-mêmes
n'avons pas d'ingénieurs technicien etc
ou d'architecte formé à notre rôle c'est
aussi je dis ça parce que le le gros des
thématiques abordées lors de ces
conseils c'est vraiment de la rénovation
et beaucoup de rénovation énergétique
donc voilà une piste quand même pour
être peut-être juste de mentionner
toutes ces structures là
voilà donc on fait pas de maîtrise
d'oeuvre la rénovation énergétique ça
passe par le Conseil des particuliers
mais pas que on conseille les
collectivités aussi pour leur bâtiment
leurs propres bâtiments publics
on est aussi sur de la rénovation alors
on est cité aujourd'hui dans le code de
l'énergie quand il y avait les spreads
etc donc on sait avec la loi ça a permis
de reconnaître et d'amplifier le rôle
des séries en matière de rénovation
énergétique on a des ce qui sont
appliqués dans le programme ça etc ce
qui n'est pas sans poser de difficultés
parce que le programme un raisonnement à
l'acte marchand on va dire alors que
nous ne sommes pas sur ce modèle
économique là
donc c'est un petit peu compliqué
aujourd'hui je pense que en tant que
réseau national on ne peut que se
féliciter des efforts qui sont faits il
y a réellement un coup d'accélérateur on
le sent qui est mis
pour que on arrive enfin quand même à
massifier un peu cette rénovation qu'on
n'arrive à en parler davantage qu'il ait
des dispositifs qui convergent qui voilà
maintenant
bon il y a peut-être aussi un peu de
confusion entre qu'est-ce qui est privé
qu'est-ce qui est public il faut
peut-être améliorer un peu notamment
pour la compagnateur rénove et puis
voilà et c'est peut-être y mettre un peu
plus de moyens toutefois
puisqu'effectivement
ça suit aussi pas mal d'années où ce
sujet-là n'était pas forcément à
l'agenda politique comme il l'a
aujourd'hui donc c'est peut-être un peu
logique aussi qu'on est un effort
financier peut-être un peu plus
important et puis qu'on mobilise les
ingéniers territoriales qui sont en
place quoi voilà je veux pas trop
développer là je vais laisser la parole
alors monsieur le président
alors directeur j'ai un président de
conseil administration
merci de votre invitation
je voulais juste préciser en
introduction que je suis directeur
d'école d'architecture mais aussi
architecte praticien et enseignants
chercheurs et à ce titre
disposant d'une expérience sur les
questions de réhabilitation je voulais
simplement préciser que donc il y a 20
écoles d'architectures école nationale
supérieure d'architecture qui sont
répartis sur tout le territoire national
et nous accueillons environ 20 000
étudiants on accueille chaque année 3300
étudiants en première année et on
diplôme environ 2500 Masters chaque
année et 1500 architectes habilité à la
maîtrise d'oeuvre le tout accompagné par
1736 enseignants et 723 agents
administratifs et techniques les écoles
d'architecture sont réparties
disons 600 Île-de-France ou quatre en
aura il y en a il y a deux régions qui
n'ont pas de d'école d'architecture le
centre Val de Loire et la Bourgogne
Franche-Comté sans parler de l'outre-mer
puisque seule la Réunion accueille une
formation à l'architecture qui est une
antenne de l'ENSA de Montpellier
les écoles d'architecture ont connu une
évolution majeure depuis 30 ans
puisqu'elles sont passées de d'écoles
professionnelles à des écoles de type
universitaire puisque en 2006 nous avons
mis en place la liste Licence Master
Doctorat et donc on délivre des diplômes
ayant en grade universitaire jusqu'au
doctorat
ce qui est l'équivalent des cursus des
universités européennes
on a aussi développé cette occasion de
nombreux diplômes et de formation en
parallèle notamment liées à la question
de la réhabilitation avec les écoles
d'ingénieurs de design de Master
spécialisés avec les universités et donc
on a su adapter depuis quelques années
l'offre de formation à cette réalité
multiple on a aussi
garder conserver le caractère
professionnelisant de la formation
puisque les architectes praticiens
interviennent dans nos établissements
pour préparer une profession réglementée
le métier d'architecte mais aussi aux
métiers de l'Architecture d'une manière
générale dans toutes ces exceptions et
cette double nature académique et
professionnelle des écoles
d'architecture c'est une de nos riches
de la richesse de nos formations si on
regarde un peu l'historique de tous les
documents produits sur les écoles
d'architecture depuis 20 ans elle
dispose tous d'un tous d'un chapitre
concernant les questions d'intervention
dans l'existant de réhabilitation on
peut regarder les arrêter 2005 qui parle
de la formation des architectes dans
lesquels il y a un chapitre spécifique à
ces questions le rapport du député Felts
sur l'enseignement de supérieur de la
recherche en architecture en 2013 le
rapport blush sur la création
architecturale en 2014 la stratégie
nationale pour l'architecture en 2015
stratégie qui a été annoncée récemment
être revu ou relancé par la ministre de
la Culture le plan national en faveur
des espaces protégés du sénateur d'eau
jusqu'en 2016 comporte aussi un chapitre
sur la formation des architectes à la
question de la réhabilitation la
stratégie pure annuelle du patrimoine en
2017 de la ministre unicenne et au sein
des écoles d'architecture et du
ministère de la Culture il y a eu deux
rapports internes en 2003 et 2011 sur
cette question spécifique alors
peut-être que s'il y a eu des rapports
c'est aussi parce que c'était une
question prégnante on va dire puisqu'on
est beaucoup d'architectes à pas
forcément avoir eu de formation il y a
20 ou 30 ans sur ces questions
il y a une première enquête qui a été
menée par LensOn Normandie que je dirige
sais pas moi le directeur à l'époque
mais en 2018 c'est une enquête qui était
financée par le ministère des
transitions et pas le ministère de la
Culture et qui démontrait déjà donc en
2018 une certaine photographie de l'état
des formations dans les écoles
d'architecture avec environ 155
enseignements dispensés dans les vins
écoles et il entrait à la question de
l'intervention dans l'existant c'est
cette enquête n'était pas complètement
exhaustive mais ça démontrait déjà une
certaine photographie et qu'en gros à
des degrés divers on disposait déjà de
niveau de formation toutes les écoles
formées pas forcément tous les étudiants
pour le dire simplement il y a une
deuxième enquête qui a été menée en 2020
qui a été financé par FEEBAT qui est un
programme de financement de la
rénovation de l'économie d'énergie par
EDF et qui a été portée par le réseau
ensa Eko qui est un réseau d'enseignants
chercheurs sur le les questions
écologiques qui est recensé 285
enseignements comportant en partie tout
ou partie des modules concernant la
rénovation énergétique là c'était
vraiment le thème
spécifique de cette enquête dans 17 N-SA
qui avait répondu à l'enquête en master
ayant licence et globalement ce qui est
intéressant dans cette enquête c'est ça
montre que il y a environ que 30% des
enseignements qui sont dédiés à plus de
50% sur la question de la rénovation
énergétique parce que les enseignants
les écoles d'architecture gardent
disons un attachement très fort à l'idée
que la formation elle doit se faire de
manière plus globale et pas seulement se
concentrer avec des aspects purement
techniques mais vraiment avoir une
vision large de la de la problématique
avec une visée aussi pluridisciplinaire
qui fait la force de nos établissements
et de nos formations la dernière enquête
elle est en cours les travaux devraient
être publiés d'ici peu en tout cas
présenter au financeur la Caisse des
dépôts en jeu prochain donc là je
participe directement à ce travail avec
le réseau architecture patrimoine et
création qui est un autre réseau
d'enseignants chercheurs des ensa et ça
porte sur l'intervention dans l'existant
c'est financé par l'appel à
manifestation d'intérêt sur les métiers
d'avenir avec l'idée de financer des
nouvelles formations donc on aura aussi
le la proposition de nouvelles
formations dans le cadre de ce projet là
396 enseignants donc en gros 400 ont été
identifiés ce qui veut dire que on est
dans un doublement de l'enquête de 2018
donc ça veut dire qu'on poursuit on va
dire une diffusion des plus en plus
large de la formation des architectes
alors il y a un petit biais qui est le
DSA de l'école de Chaillot qui comporte
à lui seul 140 enseignements mais
puisque c'est dédié uniquement à cette
question là mais globalement on observe
un développement de ces de ces
formations
et donc chaque école comporte environ
une vingtaine d'enseignements qui sont
dédiés à la question de l'intervention
sur sur l'existant donc ça se diffuse au
sein des écoles et globalement ce qu'il
reste à faire c'est à structurer une
formation
on va dire avec des modules de
compétences qui soient
acquis dans des vins ça voilà puisque le
chaque école a son propre programme et
on peut s'assurer d'un certain nombre de
compétences acquises notamment en
licence dans les fondamentaux notamment
sur les questions de relever de
diagnostic qui sont les premières bases
de connaissances de l'architecte sur ce
sujet là et puis aussi la connaissance
du bâti ancien qui reste une formation
qui est peu dispensée dans les écoles en
master chaque école dispose en général
d'un ou plusieurs domaines d'études de
spécialisation sur la question de
l'existant à divertitres à diverses
échelles
voilà donc les étudiants ont une
capacité on va dire de s'orienter en
master vers une spécialisation plus
importante et puis après on a un certain
nombre de diplômes de spécialisation qui
existent vous pouvez en avoir la liste
si vous le souhaitez ce qui apparaît
c'est que aussi c'est enseignements sont
très enfin la plupart du temps articulé
aux questions de transition numérique et
transition écologique
puisque c'est des enjeux qui sont
complètement articulés et qui font
l'objet notamment de réflexion dans ce
cadre de cette ami pour proposer
justement des formations nouvelles
l'image de ce qui peut se passer dans
d'autres universités européennes il y a
une demande de plus en plus forte et ça
c'est cette enquête qui le montre au
travers des enquêtes auprès des
enseignants que les étudiants sont en
demande de plus en plus de se voir
augmenter leur formation dans ce domaine
là à l'école l'architecture de Normandie
où nous avons un master en
réhabilitation qui existe depuis une
vingtaine d'années c'est un motif de de
candidature à l'école clairement en
dehors du secteur de la Normandie donc
on voit bien l'attrait en tout cas qui
est de la part des jeunes à s'intéresser
à ce sujet ce qui n'était peut-être
moins le cas il y a une vingtaine
d'années
il y a
donc aussi une demande de pouvoir
augmenter la part d'inscription de ces
formations dans des cadres réels puisque
voilà l'intervention de l'existant on
peut pas se conceptualiser en dehors
d'une situation particulière et
notamment dans le cadre de partenariat
avec des élus et des collectivités
locales qui sont une de nos forces de
nos écoles puisqu'on est en capacité de
démontrer que l'architecte est un acteur
majeur de la rénovation de
l'intervention dans l'existant et auprès
des populations et des élus ce travail
de formation et de d'intervention peut
tout à fait être pertinent et
intéressant le terme de rénovation
énergétique dans ces 396
présentation d'enseignement des prisons
que 19 fois et c'est pour les raisons
que j'ai déjà évoqué sur la l'enquête
fibat il y a globalement on présentera
les conclusions de cette étude mais
effectivement le besoin d'un
renforcement d'un certain nombre de
modules techniques dans les dans les
formations
avec aussi la question de des moyens et
des capacités des ressources humaines et
financières des écoles qui n'ont pas
évolué en tant que capacité d'accueil
depuis 20 ans puisqu'il n'y a pas
d'évolution contrairement à tout
l'enseignement supérieur qui est en gros
a augmenté d'une vingtaine de % ses
capacités d'accueil les écoles
d'architecture sont restées sur leur
capacité de 1997 comme un ministère de
la Culture a récupéré la tutelle des
écoles
pour éventuellement anticiper quelques
questions je voulais simplement
faire un focus sur trois petits points
le premier concerne la dénomination de
la commission parce que le terme de
rénovation énergétique disons
restreint probablement fortement le
sujet peut-être à des saints mais c'est
pas qu'une question
sémantique ça traduit aussi des réelles
difficultés
à anticiper le problème de manière plus
globale le terme de rénovation suppose
une remise à neuf avec tout ce que ça
suppose derrière comme matériel
matériaux apportés et un bilan carbone
qui peut être éventuellement défavorable
alors qui est tout un panel de types
d'interventions qu'on pourrait préciser
et décliner et puis énergétique elle
suppose aussi une focale quasiment
exclusive sur la question de la
consommation énergétique du bâtiment
dans son fonctionnement alors que
l'impact environnemental évidemment est
plus complexe que cela et ça traduire
comme je l'observe en promenant dans les
campagnes normandes mais c'est vrai dans
n'importe quel territoire des longères à
pain de bois et torchiques qui sont
isolés
par l'extérieur avec du polystyrène des
fenêtres en PVC du barrage plastique et
ça c'est une rénovation énergétique
évidemment le résultat peut être très
contestable sur le plan environnemental
notamment des matières apportées mais
aussi la mise en danger du bâtiment
lui-même puisqu'il n'est plus laissé
capacité de perspirance et je parle pas
de l'impact sur le vivant et la
dimension écologique les architectes
insistent donc pour que les politiques
publiques ne soient pas segmentaires
mais qu'elle privilégie un diagnostic
global qui intègre toutes les dimensions
et je reprends là sur l'aspect des
formations des architectes puisque on a
assisté énormément là-dessus qui intègre
les questions des usages de la valeur
patrimoniale des techniques de
construction d'origine les
fonctionnements
les techniques modernes d'amélioration
des performances énergétiques le confort
des bâtiments etc etc le deuxième point
concerne la recherche scientifique qui
est un des domaines
directifs fait partie de notre périmètre
puisqu'on les écoles nationales
supérieures
qui permet donc la production de
connaissances et l'innovation et ce
qu'il faut de manière objective observer
c'est que les structures de recherche
qui travaillent aujourd'hui dans le
domaine de la construction au delà même
de la question de la réhabilitation
dans le domaine de la construction
l'architecture ou du patrimoine sont
dispersés dans des ministères et des
structures épars
sans capacité réelle à se fédérer ou à
structurer de manière
disons globale et à faire des
partenariats évidemment des partenariats
ponctuels existent on travaille avec
l'ADEME on travaille avec certains
travails le lrmh etc et pour disposer
d'une meilleure connaissance du bâti
nous ne disposons pas de structures de
données statistiques fiables il existe
des données économiques à l'INSEE des
données démographiques à l'inné à l'Inde
les données
disons de masse sur la caractéristiques
du bâti n'existe pas la fiabilité de ces
données n'est pas présente et donc on a
très peu de capacités de pouvoir opérer
des politiques publiques qui sont
fiables à partir du moment où on n'a pas
une connaissance
pertinente et on arrive à des politiques
publiques qui estiment qu'entre 1948 et
74 on a affaire à des passoires
thermiques alors que c'est en partie
faux et surtout sa globalise les
solutions alors que l'intérêt de
l'intervention de l'architecte c'est
qu'il identifie une solution adaptée à
chaque situation et ben c'est un des
exemples c'est le décret sur les travaux
embarqués qui imposent des ite
c'est voilà un peu comme si dans toutes
les cuisines de France un menu ou une
recette
c'est souvent contradictoire et
contraire aux intérêts même du bâtiment
comme j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure et
d'autres laboratoires en Europe peuvent
on fait la démonstration de la
pertinence de la recherche un des
exemples c'est le laboratoire de Sam de
l'École polytechnique fédérale de
Lausanne qui a par exemple étudié un
grand ensemble des années 60 et qui a
fait la démonstration
qu'avec une intervention fine et
précautionneuse
qui préserve le patrimoine les
caractéristiques architecturales
d'origine on pouvait deux fois moins
cher en atteignant 80% des performances
normatives et c'est vraiment ce type
d'études qu'on a besoin de mener sauf
que nos structures de recherche n'ont
pas du tout les capacités comme d'autres
structures européennes à pouvoir
développer des programmes de recherche
autant sur le spatial l'agriculture le
cancer l'État c'est doté d'instituts
nationaux de recherche autant sur la
ville sur la construction
voilà pour l'instant les structures qui
financent des de la recherche et de
l'innovation sont épars et permettent
difficilement en tout cas aux écoles
d'architecture des embarqué dans des
programmes je dirais massif
et alors qu'on le fait un peu je peux
donner l'exemple d'une doctorante que en
doctorat en contratif au sein du
bailleur social Habitat 76 qui va
élaborer une stratégie d'intervention
sur les patrimoine du logement
individuel de ce bailleur et la présence
d'une architecte chercheuse au sein
d'une structure de d'un bailleur social
est en train de complètement transformer
leur façon et leur approche notamment
comme je l'ai dit en intégrant les
questions de qualité architecturale de
qualité d'usage le dernier point
concerne l'ingénierie de projet et je
pense que je serai là dessus complété
par par mes collègues du conseil
l'ingénierie de projet qui est trop
souvent marginalisé dans les dispositifs
de financement des politiques publiques
et notamment en particulier l'émission
de l'architecte
globalement on peut estimer à 1% le coût
de cette ingénierie par rapport à un
coût global d'opération si on prend en
compte le foncier le le l'ingénierie de
projet les coûts financiers liés aux
emprunts etc par contre évidemment c'est
un impact majeur sur la capacité du
projet à tenir des coûts et à être
pertinent d'un point de vue
architectural et urbain on peut citer
l'exemple de l'agence ELIET Teleman qui
est intervenue sur un patrimoine d'un
bailleur à Fontainebleau qui a
ce bâtiments étaient destinés à la
démolition au regard des premières
études menées l'arrivée d'un architecte
dans les études au travers de sondages
d'une connaissance ancien de recherche
historique a démontré toutes les
capacités et les spécificités du
bâtiment encore une fois la
globalisation de ce patrimoine construit
après 1948 le dessert dans des
opérations concrètes ici en l'occurrence
il y avait des agrégats de bouzzolane
qui était intégrés dans les panneaux de
béton qui donnaient une caractéristique
10 de performance d'isolation supérieure
à ce qui était imaginé à travers un DPE
prix un peu au doigt mouillé et
aujourd'hui la rénovation a été faite en
label BBC sans isence isolation par
extérieur on a donc trop souvent des
modèles normatifs qui sont issus de la
construction neuve et qui sont
appliquées de manière
identique et sans transfert sans
évolution sur la construction existante
et ce qui on s'est aboutit à selon les
cycles financiers tous les 20 ans de
financement des opérations de rénovation
à côté de l'école il y a des bailleurs
sociaux qui sont en train de démonter
l'ITE qui a été posée il y a 20 ans pour
en remettre une autre et voilà le bilan
carbone de l'ensemble est assez peu
favorable donc une des pistes de
financement c'est aussi faire une des
pistes c'est aussi de réflexion c'est la
question de l'évaluation de la qualité
architecturale des interventions au sein
même des financeurs qui soient public ou
privé
alors Monsieur le vous voulez reprendre
la parole où on laisse les questions à
Monsieur le rapporteur
oui
donc je souscrit absolument à tout ce
qui vient d'être dit
si je reprends un peu vos questions que
vous nous aviez effectivement transmis
d'abord vous nous demandiez quel était
le rôle de l'architecte dans la
rénovation énergétique d'un bâtiment le
rôle de l'architecte est le même
effectivement dans la rénovation
énergétique finalement que dans la
construction en général c'est d'abord
d'accompagner le client dans la
formation de son projet de concevoir
prescrirait chiffrer ce projet de
participer à la sélection des
entreprises et analyser les devis par la
suite il suit le chantier il coordonne
les entreprises il assiste le client
pour la réception de ce chantier ça
c'est la mission de l'architecte la base
de sa mission dans le cadre de la
rénovation énergétique effectivement
il conçoit le projet de rénovation il
intéresse aussi au budget du client donc
de pour pouvoir correspondre aussi aux
possibilités de ce client c'est là où
effectivement les aides publiques
rentrent un peu plus
dans la ligne de mire
c'est un tiers de confiance indépendant
comme je voulais préciser donc
et il embarque dans les réflexions dans
la conception de ce projet effectivement
une réflexion globale
je confirme que le prisme effectivement
de énergétique
n'est pas quelque chose qui est
globalisant et l'architecte ça
fonctionne c'est aussi de regarder la
qualité d'usage et l'amélioration de
valeur patrimoniale de ce bien qui peut
profiter de cette opportunité de la
rénovation énergétique s'améliorer
si on fait une digression la loi
aujourd'hui permet une accumulation par
exemple de ma prime rénove et ma Primada
ce qui est très bien parce que ça permet
aussi dans la perspective du
vieillissement de la population
envisager une évolution des biens parce
que les particuliers les privés vont pas
peut-être entreprendre plusieurs fois
des travaux au sein de leur logement et
leur bien
pour le public c'est encore autre chose
donc nous préconisons
un diagnostic architectural et technique
globale à ce titre là et
pour ceci les architectes depuis
particulièrement aussi depuis le covid
ont pris énormément le virage et ils ont
pris acte de la situation des cris
successives non seulement de
l'amélioration de la crise climatique
mais également l'amélioration de la
qualité des logements des Français et
leur cadre de vie
87% des architectes déclare avoir dirigé
des chantiers des opérations de
rénovation depuis 2020 donc il commence
à en faire il sont il commence à se
former massivement dans le cadre des
programmes qui ont été cités comme
feeback il y a 2500 architectes qui ont
suivi cette formation de purement
rénovation énergétique mais d'autres
formations
globalisantes sont effectivement faites
et suivis par les architectes je signale
que la formation est obligatoire et il
faut 20 heures de formation par an pour
formation continue
pour chaque architecte
et nous avons pour mission de surveiller
à ce que ce soit fait
des questions
je vous en prie
[Musique]
non mais déjà peut-être revenir sur ce
qui a été dit non déjà sur le titre
effectivement sur le fait qu'on soit sur
des en matière de rénovation énergétique
mais c'est sur l'évaluation des
politiques publiques parce que c'est
justement le cas enfin c'est que pour
l'instant nous le but de la commission
d'enquête c'est justement de se pencher
sur cette question là et effectivement
ça fera partie d'ailleurs des
conclusions qu'on pourra qu'on pourra
avoir c'est vrai que dans les différents
déplacements qu'on a pu faire et puis on
en a encore discuter hier notamment avec
les bailleurs sociaux c'est justement un
des éléments qui est ressorti
c'est-à-dire que quand on travaille sur
la question de l'accessibilité sur la
question de la rénovation de la
réhabilitation
sur la question énergétique forcément on
va aller beaucoup plus loin et au
contraire ça va être
enfin soit via la rénovation thermique
soit à l'inverse quand on travaille sur
un bâtiment ça va pas être aussi
l'occasion de travailler sur la
rénovation thermique c'était le cas par
exemple les meilleurs sociaux qui nous
disent bah par exemple qui réfléchissent
ensuite à l'amélioration sur la mise en
place de balcons sur l'amélioration du
du type de logement sur l'aménagement
urbain aussi sur fraîcheur etc parce que
du coup il peut y avoir des
interventions communes entre
l'intervention sur le bâtiment et puis
l'intervention
urbain à côté aussi et c'est ce qu'on a
pu ce qu'on a pu d'ailleurs voir en réel
en Isère de notre déplacement donc
évidemment que cette enfin voilà ça fait
partie des évidemment des préoccupations
sur lequel on travaille non moi j'avais
plutôt des enfin j'avais déjà une
question justement sur le sur le l'ordre
sur la question parce que je sais que
vous avez été très critique et puis vous
aussi sur la question du RGE et j'irai
peut-être plus globalement sur la
formation des entreprises donc du coup
si vous pouviez un petit peu revenir sur
cet aspect là parce que ça qu'on pose
beaucoup de questions sur la aussi la
qualité des réalisations parce que
encore faut-il que
que voilà faire les réalisations donc
encore faut-il que derrière elle soit à
la fois soit efficace qu'on est un
résultat à tout point de vue d'ailleurs
architecture sur les bons choix en type
de matériaux effectivement pour pas
qu'on revienne dessus au bout de 5 ou 10
ans et donc sur un fonctionnement actuel
de dire bon ben voilà on a une
entreprise qui a la belle RGE et donc on
estime que ça suffit que c'est que du
coup ça suffit je dirais à la qualité
des travaux donc avoir votre avis à
votre avis là-dessus et notamment sur on
avait pas mal de retour sur plutôt avoir
alors quand il y a une maîtrise d'oeuvre
évidemment il y a pas de souci puisque
le suivi et la réception etc sont faites
mais quand il y en a pas et donc c'est
quand même sur une grande partie quand
on parle de rénovation thermique et
notamment sur l'individuel
notamment par exemple on nous a enfin
voilà dans les idées qui sont ressorties
c'est d'avoir quelque chose un petit peu
type consuel pour l'électricité c'est à
dire à minima en tout cas un contrôle
à posteriori quoi enfin des travaux pour
pouvoir
pour pouvoir pour enfin voir cette ce
contrôle là donc je vais avoir votre
votre avis là-dessus
votre avis aussi sur du coup
l'accompagnateur Renov qui est en train
de se mettre en place sachant que
l'architecte pourrait devenir
incompatilateur Renov donc en tout cas
ça fait partie des des possibilités donc
avoir votre avis aussi sur la position
de l'architecte en tout cas en tant
qu'accompagnateur Renov
à la fois sur Oui l'intérêt la
compagnateur rénov et l'intérêt que
justement ça soit l'architecte qui
puisse le devenir en tout cas avoir
votre avis votre avis là-dessus et puis
ensuite en termes de photos globalement
de formation
c'est vrai que sur la question on va
dire rénovations thermiques et sur
sous-est là mais aussi sur la sur la
question on va dire plus largement
matériaux biosourcés on est allé donc du
coup on a rencontré la directrice de
l'école d'architecture de Grenoble et
puis on est allé aux Grands Ateliers de
l'île d'Abeau donc avec justement ce
dispositif assez intéressant à la fois
de recherche et de croisement entre
architectes entreprises
compagnon etc et donc d'avoir vraiment
justement à la fois une recherche sur
les sur le bâtiment existant mais aussi
sur des appels nouveaux matériaux mais
en tout cas matériaux biosourcés etc
et c'est vrai que du coup je pose aussi
la question de la formation justement
des articles autour de ce type de
matériaux et sur la préconisation de ce
type de matériaux en lien aussi avec des
filières qui peuvent se mettre en place
localement donc ça c'est aussi un aspect
qui nous paraît qui nous paraît
important et qui peut être aussi des
réponses justement sur le sur le bâti
patrimoine ou autre mais pas que
d'ailleurs parce que ça peut être une
réponse beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
globale donc voilà déjà dans un premier
temps les questions merci
merci oui
avant de parler des RGE je voulais
préciser une chose effectivement
la problématique actuelle qu'on traite
le plus souvent dans les rénovations
c'est aussi la question de réchauffement
climatique c'est à dire que le prisme
c'est pas que le prisme de effectivement
de
l'énergie et les passoires thermiques
mais aussi le confort d'été et le
confort d'été étant un vrai sujet le
jour où on préconise effectivement de de
d'isoler à 100% une maison
de manière assez monotage par moment ça
ça me fait venir au RGE
ça fait que par la suite effectivement
le bâtiment peut ne pas respirer et
peut-être que de mettre un balcon ça ne
suffit pas parce qu'on a envie aussi à
l'intérieur de la maison être
confortable et pouvoir mieux supporter
ces degrés qui augmentent chaque année
et qu'on peut le constater même si on
fait tous des efforts pour le baisser
donc ça c'était une précision importante
parce que ça fait partie du travail
global que font les architectes en ce
qui concerne les RGE le premier jour
quand ça a été mis en place ça allait
dans le bon sens c'est toujours bien que
l'entreprise et un label c'est très
rassurant de savoir que les entreprises
sont un peu plus sachant ont été formés
pour faire chose mais le problème c'est
que quand vous avez uniquement une
entreprise de fenêtres RGE qui vient
chez vous ou de chaudière et qui qui met
en place sa solution c'est une solution
qui effectivement nous regarde pas
l'ensemble du confort justement de
l'habitation même l'ensemble du problème
énergétique si on regarde que par ce
biais là et effectivement ça me sert à
rien de changer les fenêtres si votre
grenier n'est pas isolé donc c'est un
peu un regard global qu'il faut avoir et
ça a été ça je pense les critiques dont
vous parlez au niveau du RGE par la
suite ça a été beaucoup de discussions
aussi pour démontrer que la formation
des architectes leur permettait d'emblée
de prétendre à savoir faire qui faisait
que eux ils avaient pas besoin de ce
label RGE pour pouvoir intervenir et ça
a été acquis effectivement nous avons pu
avancer sur ce sujet là donc aujourd'hui
moi je pense que
tout cet argent public qui est en train
d'être mis sur la table
on peut dire que c'est insuffisant sur
certains niveaux sur certains sujets
notamment de l'ingénierie mais cet
argent
peut être aujourd'hui gaspillé si on ne
regarde que
la rénovation par des monototages voilà
ça c'est très important et je pense que
c'est le sujet principal par rapport à
ça
les consuels effectivement c'est le
sujet de la réception des chantiers donc
effectivement il faut réfléchir est-ce
qu'on veut avoir
qui vient conseiller en amont qui
préconise diagnostic et préconise des
travaux à faire qui disparaît par la
suite le client se retrouve avec
l'entreprise qui fait et après on fait
venir une tierce personne pour contrôler
est-ce que c'est ça le dispositif qu'on
peut mettre en place ou bien on fait
appel à des femmes et ont de l'art
quelque part assermenté qui vont pouvoir
globalement depuis le l'amant du sujet
conseillé suivre le chantier aider à
choisir ses entreprises vérifier qui
sont bien RGE et qui sont assurés parce
qu'il y a une question d'assurance aussi
bien pour les entreprises que pour les
acheter qui interviennent et par la
suite naturellement réceptionne et
vérifie si le travail est bien fait
voilà donc peut-être que si on est dans
une idée aussi de d'accélération pour
aider les ménages qui aujourd'hui sont
devant des problématiques de passoire
énergétique et qui ont besoin d'aide et
il faut aller vite
la solution ça serait que les aides
soient regroupées à un guichet unique et
que les intervenants aussi soient
souvent plus globalisées qui puisse
avoir un regard plus général sur la
problématique de bâtiment à rénover
voilà un peu le
regard que peuvent avoir les architectes
là-dessus
et ça c'est en partie une réponse aussi
sur la question de l'accompagnateur
rénov ça va dans le bon sens c'est
beaucoup mieux qu'on ait un
accompagnateur Renov c'est même
indispensable aujourd'hui mais peut-être
que c'est une mission qui est encore
partielle et qui va falloir donner les
astuces pour l'accompagner et les être
publics pour que les particuliers
puissent avoir les moyens aussi de faire
appel à des architectes ou des bureaux
d'études qui puissent les accompagner
dans la construction pour les matériaux
bio sourcés les architectes
du coup la solution idéale ça serait
gros qu'il maîtrise d'oeuf qui a un
architecte pour l'ensemble des des
chantiers de rénovation
d'accord
mais est-ce que du coup on sera en
capacité de le faire parce que c'est une
chose de se dire dans l'idéal on peut
avoir l'ensemble des chantiers de
rénovation avec une maîtrise d'oeuvre un
suivi complet voilà qui va bien mais en
gros voilà est-ce que à la fois on est
en capacité en termes de
non-marchitectes en termes de formation
et parce qu'il y a aussi du coup
dans cette politique est mise en place
une question aussi de
d'objectif de 1050 enfin 2030 2050 et
donc du coup d'aller vite quoi en tout
cas rapidement et donc voilà du coup
est-ce que vous estimez que c'est des
choses qui sont qui sont possibles ce
sont des choses qui sont possibles mais
tout à fait dans le sens de mon confrère
effectivement les écoles d'architecture
aujourd'hui il faut que ça évolue
c'est-à-dire que si on ne peut pas avoir
le même nombre d'architectes qui a qui a
30 ans 40 ans et vouloir faire beaucoup
de travail en plus alors que tous ces
architectes aujourd'hui sont déjà
occupés à faire beaucoup de choses donc
ça c'est une réalité effectivement que
vous soulevez on n'est pas assez
nombreux mais il faut pas oublier aussi
que c'est comme c'est un changement de
paradigme il y a beaucoup de
construction neuves qui vont pas se
faire et que les architectes vont
pouvoir s'atteler aussi à faire de la
rénovation et ça c'est une réalité
je voudrais pas rentrer dans nos
discussions sur l'objectif ça etc mais
c'est une réalité que aujourd'hui on va
avoir de toute façon dans les marchés
publics les archives ctes nous prenons
acte aujourd'hui que les commandes ont
vraiment changé aujourd'hui on nous
demande beaucoup plus de faire de la
rénovation que de construire des
nouvelles écoles ou d'autres bâtiments
publics donc bon ça peut s'équilibrer en
partie comme ça mais il est sûr qu'on va
besoin on va avoir besoin de nouveaux
architectes sur le marché très bien
formés et qui puisse faire ce travail là
et qui en a pas assez aujourd'hui moi
j'attire l'attention je vous allez me
dire dans l'immédiat comment on fait si
vous êtes passé nombreux
il y a une chose qui est très importante
c'est que le diagnostic diagnostiqueur
mais aussi celui qui va faire le
diagnostic réglementaire etc il faut
absolument qu'il soit assuré parce que
sinon n'importe quelle personne non
formée qui va venir se prétendre
diagnostiquer et qui disent à ménage
vous vous êtes de votre diagnostic et à
temps et que on peut pas le contrôler on
peut pas être sûr si ce trompe pas
contre qui se retourner ça ne peut pas
fonctionner pendant ce temps on a dit
d'accord et on a payé les primes de
l'État et l'argent et dépensé donc ça
c'est la limite du système
aujourd'hui vous vous faites appel à
nous lors des architectes nous tout ce
qu'on peut vous faire c'est de répondre
présent voilà après peut-être qu'on
n'est pas assez nombreux il faut aussi
les ingénieurs les sachants il faut des
gens sachant qui ont aussi une assurance
pour assurer derrière pour cette partie
là peut-être juste pour compléter très
rapidement effectivement ça pose le la
question du nombre mais on pourrait très
bien l'envisager par exemple pour des
rénovations globales c'est à dire que
quand Lana donne une aide qui est un peu
une aide de substantielle dans le cas
d'une rénovation globale bah là le
recours à une maîtrise d'oeuvre est
obligatoire parce que on le retrouve
déjà dans l'attestation de travaux cette
idée de consuel dont on vous parlez
c'est-à-dire que normalement l'auditeur
l'auditeur énergétique doit sur la base
de des factures qui lui est fourni qui
lui sont fournies pardon par le par le
ménage établir une attestation alors il
va pas sur le chantier mais sur la base
de ces factures il établit une
attestation comme quoi les travaux
auraient été réalisés conformément à ce
qu'il a prescrit donc il y a déjà une
petite une vérification mais on franchit
toujours pas le Rubicon je dirais qui
est de contrôler c'est à dire paramètres
d'oeuvre donc là on parle de la
compagnateur l'assistant
l'accompagnateur Reno pardon
l'accompagnateur Renov il est clairement
indiqué sur le site du ministère que
c'est un Amos un assistant maîtrise
d'ouvrage alors que quand on regarde sa
mission qui est quand même d'accompagner
le ménage de cerner un peu son projet de
de l'aiguiller vers des entreprises
d'analyser un peu les devis de
l'assister un peu dans la réception des
travaux on voit que c'est quand même une
mission qui s'apparente à de la maîtrise
d'oeuvre mais quand n'est pas tout à
fait non il y a quand même un flou je
pense qui est assez qui est assez
entretenu à ce niveau là et le le
gouvernement peut-être pour des
certainement pour des questions je sais
pas peut-être qu'il y a beaucoup de
à l'intérêt de d'autres peut-être ou des
questions de coûts mais ne franchis pas
ce Rubicon qui serait pour certains
projets parce qu'il y a quand même un
objectif de performance énergétique
globale de la rénovation on s'aperçoit
que le monogès ça sert à rien maintenant
ça devient acté dans toutes les études
tout ce qui est monogeste de rénovation
ça sert pas à grand-chose donc dans le
cadre d'une rénovation globale là il
pourrait effectivement y avoir une
montée en puissance avec la recours
systématique à un maître d'oeuvre qui
viendrait quand même contrôler tout ça
parce que comme ça il te dit il y a des
milliards qui sont injectés sur ce
marché donc ça attire des gens plus ou
moins plutôt mal intentionnés et à
partir de la faute faut réguler il faut
faire réguler par des par des sages quoi
de la présidente peut-être sur un petit
peu ce qui a été évoqué de façon moi sur
le le comment dire le recours à
l'architecte pour pour pouvoir quand
même qualifier en fait les projets qui
sont faits je ne peux que partager c'est
effectivement c'est une compétence qui
est qui serait quand même hyper
importante de mobiliser pour avoir des
projets la question qui se pose aussi
sur le particulier c'est pour ça que je
reviens sur l'approche globale c'est que
le particulier souvent il vous dit bon
ben non mais attendez j'ai 5000 euros à
investir j'ai pas plus donc dites moi
pour 5000 euros qu'est-ce qui où est-ce
que je les investis qu'est-ce qui ferait
le plus levier et là si vous n'avez pas
quelqu'un qui est en capacité de
raisonner globalement sur le bâtiment
intermédié etc ça va être très compliqué
or c'est quand même ça la clé d'entrée
souvent des particuliers elle est
budgétaire
rares sont quand même les ménages qui
qui peuvent tout faire et toute la liste
etc donc c'est quand même l'homme de
l'art qui est en capacité le mieux de
répondre à ça après moi je pense que
alors j'entends tout à fait un peu la
superposition on est aussi très proche à
la fin de la mission sur quelque chose
qui est inscrit dans la mission
d'architecte donc peut-être que là il
faut clarifier les choses moi ce que je
crois vraiment important c'est que il y
ait quand même une distinction enfin une
déontologie qui disent bien qu'à partir
du moment si on est en amont en tant
qu'architecte sur l'accompagnateur rénov
il faut pas récupérer les marchés
derrière voilà je pense qu'il faut
peut-être juste fin il faut voir comment
on régule ça en tout cas ça me paraît si
on est dans le cas du service public de
la rénovation en tout cas voilà il faut
voir peut-être comment à cet endroit là
on règle le curseur quoi vous aviez posé
la question aussi de la des
incompréhensions des difficultés de la
part des architectes concernant les
réglementations actuelles ou les
dispositifs
mais c'est pas que les architectes qu'on
a des difficultés c'est aussi les élus
et c'est aussi les habitants c'est à
dire que il y a une telle instabilité en
fait dérèglements des politiques que ça
perd quand même aussi à un moment donné
en efficacité parce que parce que les
gens sont voilà les acteurs les
décideurs privés publics sont un peu
perdus et ça faut le prendre en compte
c'est à dire qu'entre le moment où vous
parlementaire vous votez une loi
et le moment où elle arrive dans les
territoires je dirais où elle atterri
comme on dit maintenant dans les
territoires et bien qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé entre les deux qui est intervenu
pour faire en sorte que l'artisan qui
est tout seul qui a pas forcément les
moyens d'aller se former etc qui est
intervenu pour expliquer à l'élu qui a
pas les services d'une métropole que il
y a des lois nouvelles etc et que sur
ces bâtiments publics voilà donc ça
c'est pas propre au sujet de la
rénovation énergétique ses propres à
notre système français mais on a quand
même là un petit Delta qu'on auquel
n'échappe pas la question de la
rénovation énergétique et des lois et
des mesures quoi la chose que je
voudrais dire aussi je pense qu'il y a
quand même aussi une dimension
culturelle et c'est pour ça je crois
qu'on a du mal à franchir le pas c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui quand vous achetez
un véhicule vous savez très bien que
vous allez devoir changer des choses au
bout de x kilomètres etc quand vous
faites un bâtiment et qu'on vous livre
la notion de de la comment dire de la
dégradation de certains matériaux de du
devoir de de
rénover etc c'est pas entrer dans les
mœurs c'est à dire qu'on voulait un
bâtiment déjà c'était le projet de votre
vie donc vous soufflez enfin vous êtes
super content et on n'est pas dans une
approche alors globale pendant la
relation mais on n'est pas dans une
approche dans le temps c'est à dire que
ben voilà c'est vraiment pas comme
l'automobile et du coup quand la
rénovation énergétique arrive elle n'est
pas anticipée elle n'est pas anticipée
je dirais psychologiquement elle est pas
anticipée financièrement non plus donc
ça c'est quand même aussi un sujet c'est
pour ça que je crois vraiment que cette
question là elle est technique elle est
à partager entre les ingénieurs
terminants les architectes etc mais
au-delà de ça on a du mal aussi avancer
parce que c'est pas encore vraiment dans
notre culture de regarder ça comme ça et
puis peut-être aussi je voulais revenir
sur un point aussi qui est le rôle de la
formation des syndics le sujet des
copropriétés c'est quand même un gros
sujet en France et on le voit enfin on a
des syndics qui sont quand même pas
formés
à anticiper les rénovations des
bâtiments qu'ils ont en gestion
expliquer les les ben voilà la
législation les primes etc aux
propriétaires et ça c'est quand même un
gros sujet alors il y a quelques sites
en France nous on a le CE2 de 94 donc
Val-de-Marne qui travaille beaucoup sur
les notions de macopro enfin voilà il
travaille en partenariat avec d'autres
structures d'autres organismes et là on
mesure vraiment le travail qu'il y a à
faire quoi voilà parce que ce sujet déco
pro il est aujourd'hui extrêmement
handicapant dans la rénovation dans la
rénovation du patrimoine donc voilà je
voudrais juste attirer votre attention
alors je suis pas experte de ça mais
nous avons des CV qui sont qui sont
mobilisés dans ce dispositif il y a bon
je pense que dans la il faut aussi
stimuler cette qualité de rénovation et
pour ça il y a parfois des labels alors
il y a plein de labels mais il y en a un
qui est expérimentale aujourd'hui et qui
me semblerait intéressant de de
poursuivre c'est le label et synergie
ok donc à label met en place voilà qui
est gérée par une association mais qui
est surtout portée par le MTE et aussi
avec le partenariat de la culture qui
est à la balle qui s'intéresse pas
seulement aux monuments historiques mais
qui s'intéresse au bâtiment ayant un
caractère patrimonial et dans
l'obtention de ce label il y a ce double
regard entre un ingénieur spécialisé des
questions énergétiques et l'architecte
et j'en viens quand même je pense à la
question de la formation parce que je
partage tout à fait et je vois avec
plaisir qu'effectivement l'information
des architectes évolue quant à
l'intégration de la rénovation mais je
pense aussi surtout contrairement au
système allemand
il faut vraiment que ingénieur et
architecte se parlent moi j'ai vu toutes
les difficultés que nous avions nous au
sein d'un comité de pilotage ça a
expliqué à l'ADEME mais pas que que mais
c'est valable aussi je pense du côté des
architectes à regarder l'ingénieur pas
seulement comme une expert technique et
que le l'ingénieur accepte aussi
entendre la compétence de l'architecte
qui va s'intéresser à l'usage qui va
s'intéresser à ce que ça donne aussi
dans l'espace public etc donc là il y a
quand même aussi un enjeu culturel on
est dans un pays où c'est très difficile
ce dialogue là est extrêmement difficile
la place des architectes dans le comité
de pilotage ça en tant que vous dire que
c'est encore une bataille aujourd'hui
même au sein de l'ADEME c'est très
compliqué donc c'est quand même dommage
parce que ça je pense que ça ralentit
quand même pas mal de de projets donc ce
petit label est énergie aujourd'hui il
se pose la question de durée je pense
que c'est vraiment important une autre
chose mais là c'est pas la formation
c'est la question des filières
on a aujourd'hui en France certaines
filières qui sont organisées mais des
filières qui s'intéresseraient aux
matériaux bio sourcés etc ça reste quand
même vraiment à construire quoi c'est à
dire qu'on a des gens qui sont isolés
qui ont probablement des initiatives et
qui font une on le voit il y a le
Seine-et-Marne qui travaille sur le
chanvre par exemple avec le serema mais
c'est un travail monumental de mettre
autour de la table les architectes les
élus qui sont potentiellement mettre
d'ouvrage la filière de production du
chanvre comment l'applique le champ etc
dans le bâtiment donc je pense aussi
dans notre pays un travail à faire sur
les filières pour que ce soit beaucoup
plus fluide pour que quand on a des
projets des cahiers des charges qui
sortent etc derrière la chaîne se met en
place je dirais assez naturellement quoi
et on n'est pas encore aujourd'hui voilà
c'est un chantier je pense qu'il faut
vraiment ouvrir l'organisation des
filières autour des matériaux sourcils
pour que ce beaucoup plus naturel que ça
ne l'est aujourd'hui pour que les
questions
économique soit mise aussi autour de la
table pour les questions de rentabilité
pour voilà bon aujourd'hui il y a quand
même des savoirs il y a des chercheurs
aussi qui sont là-dessus il faut que
tous ces milieux là se parlent pour
vraiment avoir quelque chose dans 5 ans
qui sortent et qui marche bien quoi le
directeur puis après je crois qu'il y a
des questions de nos collègues pour
aller dans le sens de ce qui vient
d'être dit deux petites précisions la
dans les éléments les modules que l'on
repère qui sont un peu défaillants on va
dire dans les dans les formations il y a
la question de l'économie qui est un
sujet parce que disons que c'est un
débat entre est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui s'apprend en insertion
professionnelle ou au sein de l'école
malgré tout 5 ans pour former un
architecte voir six ans avec la GMO
reste très très court si vous regardez
un Compagnon du Devoir ou un médecin
c'est 10 ans donc c'est vrai que le
temps de formation est extrêmement court
et la plupart des architectes
aujourd'hui qui s'inscrivent en HMO on
fait un autre parcours de formation en
bicursus ou en postmaster ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui le parcours de formation
est plus complet mais la question de
l'économie elle est importante puisque
des jeunes formés dans des IUT
d'économies du bâtiment peuvent sortir
de leur formation avec un meilleur
salaire qu'un architecte qui a fait bac
+ 5 parce qu'ils vont maîtriser ce sujet
là peut-être que leur perspectives
d'évolution sont moins importantes mais
en tout cas au regard des des
sorties d'écoles au niveau de
rémunération il y a un gap et en fait
c'est
acteurs complémentaires on va dire la
maîtrise d'oeuvre dans des territoires
des pauvres d'architectes sont
majoritairement présents et enfin voilà
comble l'absence de
des architectes et donc il y a
certainement un renfort sur cette sur
cette question là avec notamment la
question de l'insertion pas de
l'insertion des architectes puisque
85-2% de nos diplômés obtiennent un
travail à l'issue de leur formation dans
les six mois mais de la place de que la
mise en situation professionnelle dans
le cursus de formation avec cette
difficulté des 5 ans comme je l'ai déjà
dit et l'autre point c'est la formation
continue puisque nous école
d'architecture on serait en mesure de le
faire en tout cas on est on a les
centres de ressources on a les
enseignants chercheurs qui ce qui ont
des spécialités mais nos capacités de
développement sont
quasi nuls et la formation continue elle
est plutôt prise en charge par des
organismes privés et il y a un problème
d'offre de formation des architectes qui
ont l'obligation de se former mais les
possibilités pour les écoles de
développer cette économie là et
notamment sur la réalité puisque comme
ça a été dit toute une génération
d'architectes n'ont pas été formée en
formation initiale et donc ils ont
besoin de cette formation complémentaire
et là les écoles peuvent être un centre
de ressources si nous avons les
capacités en termes de même d'ingénierie
pédagogique tout simplement avec des
emplois administratifs qui permettent
d'assurer d'assurer la mise en place de
ça sur la question de la formation de
des biosourcés je dans le sens de ce qui
a été dit alors les ateliers
d'isle-d'abeau c'est un outil absolument
extraordinaire qui
est assez exceptionnel et dans tous les
écoles d'architecture rêveraient d'avoir
sur leur site et en gros globalement
c'est à peu près ce que n'importe quel
école d'ingénieur de base a sur son site
c'est à dire que le problème c'est que
ça reste une exception alors que ça
devrait être complètement diffusé avec
des adaptations particulières il y en a
qui vont s'intéresser au numérique au
data Smart City à tout ce que vous
voulez mais
cet équipement là qui est adossé à une
fondation d'université avec qui
accueille notamment une association qui
répond à des appels à projets permettant
de financer des formes des
développements de formation c'est un
modèle économique extrêmement
intéressant et il y a pas un directeur
ou une directrice d'école qui ne
souhaite avoir ça dans son jardin que
j'ai envie de dire et la question des
matériaux biosourcés elle est présente
en grande partie pareil avec des limite
forte sur les capacités de nos
laboratoires à travailler sur ces sujets
en particulier et ça j'insiste beaucoup
sur le fait que notre tutelle du
ministère de la culture n'a pas dans son
périmètre de compétence la question de
des filières c'est ça se passe ailleurs
donc nous on peut faire beaucoup
d'efforts avec nos petits bras pour
aller chercher des partenaires locaux
parce qu'effectivement comme s'était dit
dans chaque territoire il y a des
petites associations qui fait derrière
les entreprises les artisans les
filières industriels etc qui commence à
changer tout ce système là et nous on
veut bien être partenaire de ça mais
pareil ça demande des énergies
extrêmement lourdes dont on est enfin on
n'a pas les capacités encore une fois de
administrative et de chercheurs pour
pouvoir faire ça et c'est pour ça que
quand je parlais de je sais pas un
institut de de recherche en tout cas une
structuration du financement de la
recherche et de l'innovation on a en
Normandie un plan de d'innovation de
transfert de pour aider de
l'enseignement supérieur vers les
filières industrielles
on pourrait tout à fait le faire en
Normandie sur un certain nombre de
filières notamment les fibres puisqu'on
a du lin etc mais voilà on est très très
loin de ce que les écoles d'ingénieurs
ont mis en place avec l'automobile ou
avec les énergies depuis 20 30 ou 40 ans
donc faire des chairs des chers
industriels par exemple sur ces
questions là ça nous permettrait
effectivement de financer des structures
de recherche des ateliers
d'expérimentation des Halles dans lequel
on puisse faire des tests sur des
matériaux etc etc
alors Sabine je vais te laisser la
parole parce qu'après si on doit partir
il pose cette question oui tout à
l'heure c'est pas vraiment une question
en fait vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
le sujet du du bâti patrimonial avec les
saccages qui sont durs à la aux
techniques inadaptées notamment sur les
longères en Normandie moi je suis
alsacienne et je compte exactement les
mêmes soucis chez nous en Alsace ce
problème c'est que j'ai l'impression que
le constat c'est atteintes est quand
même assez récent je trouve enfin
jusqu'à yape on appliqué du polystyrène
ou quoi c'était pas enfin je veux dire
on l'appliquait mais aujourd'hui avec la
loi climat est résilience et ses
injonctions d'isolation ça se multiplie
et et là on est en phase d'un vrai gros
problème par rapport à la pérennité de
notre patrimoine bâti en France et moi
je me réjouis vraiment de voir que en
fait les écoles d'architecture se
saisissent
de ces sujets je trouve que ce que c'est
que c'est dommage en fait que ça se
fasse qu'aujourd'hui parce que c'est
vrai que ces matériaux on les connaît
depuis longtemps la DM le serema crébat
je dirais des études qui ont été
publiées en 2011 déjà et voilà on s'en
saisit seulement aujourd'hui mais c'est
parce qu'en fait on est devant cette de
cette forme d'urgence alors comme dit
vraiment je me réjouis que les écoles
d'architecture
sont saisis c'est vrai qu'on a un gros
problème d'ingénierie pas assez
d'architectes et donc je sais qu'il y a
des collectivités notamment chez moi en
Alsace qui met à disposition de
l'ingénierie pour le bâti patrimonial
donc on travaille avec les notre c.ae
avec les parcs également qui
accompagnent les porteurs de projets que
ce soit les collectivités ou des
particuliers mais voilà donc ce que
j'entends cet après-midi me rassure même
si en même temps je sens que on est on
est dans quelque chose qui est même plus
qu'urgent parce que les premiers
saccages ont déjà commencé
oui
sur les filières ce qui est très
important un vrai frein qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui c'est c'est l'homologation
des matériaux les matériaux aujourd'hui
ne sont pas tous reconnus on peut pas
utiliser tous les matériaux qu'on
aimerait et là c'est aussi à ce niveau
là que les législateurs peuvent
intervenir et nous aider à accélérer
ceci parce qu'il y a un fort lobbing
également au niveau des matériaux pour
que les anciens matériaux continuent à
bien fonctionner et que les nouveaux ne
sont pas encore assez puissants pour
pouvoir se faire entendre donc ça c'est
un véritable frein donc je vous fais
part aujourd'hui
même si on veut les installer on a des
difficultés de normes l'autre chose qui
est en train de s'améliorer c'est
effectivement par exemple même dans le 9
mais dans la réhabilitation également
c'était l'utilisation d'un plancher bois
faisait que des fois c'était plus épais
et que on dépassait les auteurs
autorisées par les élu et qu'aujourd'hui
les nouvelles règles vont pouvoir nous
permettre de considérer que cette
épaisseur supplémentaire qui est pour
aller dans un bon sens d'un bon matériau
va nous donner des dérogations pour
pouvoir faire
augmenter la limite du PLU qui nous
empêchait de les installer donc ça c'est
c'est l'autre sujet qui est un frein qui
est en train d'être enlevé
par rapport
au bâtiment patrimoniaux je voulais
insister sur le rôle des ABF et le c'est
l'occasion en fin de signaler leur la
nécessité de leur existence qui sont
vraiment des gardiens de temple quand
même en France en France ou même
économiquement
on utilise
la beauté de notre patrimoine pour
accueillir tout le monde qui est en
admiration devant ça et qu'il faut pas
le saccager et les ABS comme les
architectes en général sont pas assez
nombreux aujourd'hui et ils apparaissent
aujourd'hui comme descenseurs alors que
il devrait aussi s'ils étaient plus
nombreux intervenir plus en amont des
sujets et être conseillé en amont
au lieu d'arriver à la fin et de dire
que c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut faire
donc là il y a un vrai travail aussi à
faire augmenter au contraire leur nombre
pour leur donner aussi plus que
possibilité de consacrer du temps aux
gens parce que beaucoup de malentendus
aussi autour des Abbès viennent du fait
qu'ils sont débordés et qui sont pas
assez nombreux
rapide pour vous avez soulevé
effectivement ce risque de de sa cage là
actuellement vous savez qu'il y a deux
audits de type d'audit il y a l'audit
réglementaire donc quand on vend une une
passoire énergétique donc c'est audit
réglementaire il fait il peut être fait
par des DPI des gens qui font les DPE et
également des architectes et des bureaux
d'études et il y a également l'audit
incitatif ma prime rénove et là il y a
actuellement une réflexion de
l'administration pour faire en sorte que
l'audit s'est audit réglementaire
remplace à terme l'audit incitative
après brenov donc avec nous ce qu'on
craint c'est que le risque de
dépréciation je dirais un peu de la
qualité de l'audit puisqu'en fait cette
audit serait réalisé par des non
professionnels du cadre bâti que sont
les maîtres d'oeuvre pardon architecte
ou bureau d'études mais par des dpistes
sous réserve d'une formation très rapide
avec bien entendu tout le risque que ça
peut engendrer de dégradation du terme
bâti d'eau du cadre bâti pardon donc ça
je pense que c'est un risque que la
Commission peut-être devrait
examiner un petit peu plus
euh de toute façon un peu plus
approfondie parce que encore une fois on
craint qu'il va y avoir une
dévalorisation de de cet audit parce
qu'en fait c'est audit on sait que c'est
la la clé pour avoir une rénovation
énergétique performante et si elle est
fait par des non professionnels du cadre
bâti on craint que ça y est se
dégradation dont vous parlez souhaite
exacerbé et en particulier bon des DPI
certes ils sont certainement compétents
mais quand ils vont dans le secteur
sauvegarder peut-être faire des
scénarios de travaux avec une isolation
par itte se faire recaler par justement
par les ABS et avec tous les risques de
contentieux qui va y avoir avec
l'acquéreur parce que quand vous avez
acquis une un bien et qu'on vous a
fourni avec ce bien un scénario de
travaux et qu'en fait ce scénario de
travaux bah il est absolument pas
réalisable voilà donc on craint que ça
ça ouvre la porte de nombreux
contentieux
pour vous répondre enfin c'est pas
vraiment une réponse mais bon toucher le
particulier c'est important
effectivement pour pas qu'effectivement
il fasse n'importe quoi et qui soit
juste un petit peu sous pression de
vendeurs on va dire de commerciaux qui
d'ailleurs ne pense pas forcément faire
mal enfin je veux dire c'est c'est
vraiment là aussi qui a le drame
la question de comment comment on éduque
les gens comment on est sensibilisa moi
je veux juste citer le succès que
rencontre les les visites
thermographiques menées par les cieux
avec les habitants avec la population
c'est à dire que ça c'est il y a un côté
à la fois ludique mais enfin qui qui
perd vite sa dimension ludique quand les
quand les les participants réalisent
effectivement tout ces trous tout ces
endroits où finalement l'argent mis dans
leur bien pour chauffer pour 6% par
finalement dans la nature quoi dans
l'espace public donc évidemment toucher
les particuliers c'est important il faut
des campagnes d'information etc mais je
pense qu'il y a un acteur qui est majeur
aussi c'est l'élu
et parce que l'élu lui sur sa commune il
entend il écoute et il voit si on
commence à critiquer des bâtiments si on
va voilà c'est quand même important donc
je pense que c'est quand même un acteur
clé et est-ce qu'il serait pas
envisageable de donner une minimum de
formation socle autour de la question de
la rénovation énergétique pour que les
élus soient davantage attentif à ce qui
se fait sur leur territoire c'est quand
même eux qui sont les voilà au côté
interpellé par les citoyens etc nous on
a un président de fédération Joël
vograsset qui comme il le dit lui-même à
force de 15 ans de Cu a été extrêmement
sensible à ça et qui maintenant fait la
chasse partout sur son secteur il trouve
effectivement des élus comme lui qui
sont attentifs mais il y a des coûts qui
partent quand même avec des bâtiments
refait avec des matériaux qui vont pas
ou qui sont refaits par l'extérieur mais
pas comme il faut etc etc donc la
question un élu c'est un décideur donc
il s'agit pas de le former aux matériaux
etc mais la question de en qualité de
décideurs de ce que voilà par rapport à
vos citoyens
vous voulez comment dire imprimer en
termes de cadre de vie parce que ce qui
est fait sur une maison très vite quand
même souvent à partir l'espace public
entre guillemets enfin est en
covisibilité de tout le monde je pense
que ça il faudrait se poser la question
d'une formation socle alors faites par
les cell ou d'autres peu importe mais
d'une formation socle qui donnerait
quand même quelques clés quelques
repères les fondamentaux va dire de la
rénovation énergétique en intégrant
cette double dimension le rôle de
l'architecte le rôle du terme
le rôle de l'artisan parce que l'élu
pour juger et pour rendre compte a
besoin quand même de cette approche
globale oui juste dire que
ce type de cas rencontré traduit aussi
un problème de culture et de
connaissance un pas seulement des
artisans mais du propriétaire de de
l'Amérique qui éventuellement autorisé
ou pas etc qui contrôle enfin de
l'ensemble des instances pour ça la
place des cieux est vraiment extrêmement
importante et c'est très très
fondamental que leur financement soit
pérennisé et qu'on est ainsi eu dans
chaque dans chaque département parce que
ce sont les acteurs de formation et de
la population et des élus en priorité et
qu'on a besoin de citoyens et des lieux
qui soient formés à l'architecture et il
y a une autre piste de réflexion aussi
c'est pour avoir rédigé moi même
plusieurs règlements de sites
patrimoniaux remarquables je me rends
compte malgré tout que
dans le dialogue notamment avec les AVF
c'est des outils qui sont extrêmement
intéressants mais qui sont très lourds à
mettre en place et je trouve toujours
curieux cet exercice de rajouter un
règlement au règlement c'est à dire
qu'on vient rajouter un règlement
patrimonial au règlement
urbain dans lequel on vient compléter
par des règles qui voilà sont pas censés
être contradictoires alors souvent les
communes font les deux en même temps
mais c'est pas vraiment le même
calendrier etc donc je sais pas dans
quelle mesure on peut enfin ça peut être
un peu simplifié dans le dans le
réglement enfin dans les procédures de
règlement
de réglementation mais aujourd'hui
beaucoup de communes hésitent au regard
du coup que ça représente de faire un
site patrimonial remarquable alors qu'en
fait c'est un outil extrêmement
intéressant de pédagogie auprès des
citoyens parce qu'on rédige des
documents dans lequel on explique la
nature des bâtiments leur typologie leur
fonctionnement leur les de tout ce qui
est hygrométrique les conforts d'été etc
tout ça est présent dans la
réglementation enfin dans le dans le
dans le document dans le diagnostic et
dans le voilà et c'est aussi un outil
qui permet de dialogue entre élus et
autorité de régulation comme la BF et
c'est on est plus soumis à une règle de
covisibilité d'un monument sur un rayon
complètement fictif de 500 mètres mais
on est vraiment sur une lecture d'un
territoire de sa constitution de ses
périmètres etc et donc là il y a
peut-être aussi dans les secteurs
patrimoniaux à trouver le la bonne
adéquation dans le l'urbanisme
réglementaire pour que ces questions
environnementales soient inclus dans le
dans le dans l'ensemble du corps on va
dire réglementaire de l'urbanisme
peut-être juste une une précision sur la
CAE sur la charte fer et si vous pouviez
nous donner un petit peu le bilan je
crois que vous aviez signé en 2019 sur
on avait signé effectivement la
charte-fer sans d'ailleurs à cette
époque avoir le droit de figurer sur la
plateforme faire
c'était un exploit voilà pour les mêmes
raisons que celles que je vous indiquez
au début donc nous signer une charte
comme ça ça veut dire que bon c'est un
sujet qui était déjà dans le réseau ciao
évidemment
mais ça veut dire que ça le booste ça
veut dire qu'à un moment donné c'est une
reconnaissance finalement plus que une
progression parce que c'est de se dire
que dans les territoires toutes ces
questions là elle enfin je veux dire
elles sont présentes parce que vous le
disiez madame d'ailleurs les
catastrophes elles sont pas
d'aujourd'hui mais on s'y intéressent
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai aussi ça donc
cette charte faire nous c'est une
reconnaissance de ce qui est fait dans
les territoires ça veut dire même si ça
nous a posé des difficultés de pas être
sur la plateforme les gens ne
comprenaient pas pourquoi vous avez
signé la chambre mais vous n'êtes pas
sur la plateforme donc il nous trouvait
pas donc ça jetait un peu le discrédit
donc on s'est trouvé un peu en ballotage
je peux lui dire
bon voilà alors on a quand même géré etc
alors pour être très transparente nous
on n'est pas capé je dirais pour faire
des enquêtes
exhaustives sur des sujets comme ça mais
ce que l'on voit c'est que c'est une
reconnaissance ça ça remet dans notre
agenda fédéral ce sujet là donc voilà
maintenant vous dire le bilan précis
qu'on peut attirer c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué parce qu'on n'a pas fait
l'enquête exhaustive là-dessus mais
signer cette charte elle est partagée ça
crée de l'émulation il y a des échanges
etc et pour nous voilà c'est ce qui fait
que ça permet une amélioration des
pratiques aussi parce que ça ça stimule
quand même voilà tous les ce qui était
un peu à l'avant-garde en avant sur ces
sujets là parce qu'ils ont fait
bénéficier à d'autres aussi dans les
territoires quoi donc voilà c'est quand
même aussi cette fonction-là de de
pouvoir dire bon ben voilà après on est
quand même très implantés dans les
territoires donc
bon ça c'est
pas forcément un élément déclenchant
voilà
votre départ je voulais je voulais faire
une précision
parmi les questions qu'on nous avait
posées si on de manière générale nous
avions nous participons nous sommes
associés à des concertations ou des
sujets si on pourrait nous faire
parvenir les questions qu'on n'aurait
pas évoqué et à travers ça donc nous
avons fait une proposition qui peut vous
intéresser parce que nous avons été
co-rapporteur du groupe de travail
numéro 3 du Conseil national de la
refondation logement et des nouvelles et
non malheureusement et on attend mais on
nous a offert des propositions dans le
cadre du groupe de travail qui
s'appelait faire du logement
l'avant-garde de la transition
écologique donc on a fait tout un tas de
propositions et parmi ces propositions
effectivement il y avait le sujet des
thermographies dans le sens où
aujourd'hui les passoires énergétiques
existent les moyens sont pas suffisants
on n'arrive pas à vite globaliser et
résoudre le problème de tout le monde
donc il va falloir prioriser de voir
quelles sont les zones prioritaires où
il va falloir intervenir chez les
passoires thermiques les plus dégradés
les plus regroupés où il y a plus de
précarité aussi au niveau de la
population et c'est thermographies
peuvent être des véritables solutions
donc si aujourd'hui il faut
rediriger l'argent public vers des
actions ça peut ça peut être une action
forte de venir faire une thermographie à
l'échelle de chaque territoire et
décider de où mettre cet argent public
et non pas distribuer de manière
générale chez n'importe quel passoir
thermique ça peut être une vraie
solution au sujet des des zones
pavillonnaires qui ont véritablement
aujourd'hui besoin d'aide qu'on les aide
à remonter cette pente de passoire entre
autres
peut-être pour compléter un effet
indirect quand même de cette de cette
signature de charte c'est
parce que tous les réseaux au niveau
national ont communiqué là-dessus auprès
des structures locales c'est le
rapprochement encore plus de structures
comme les Alecs les sérieux les Adils
ça c'est un impact voilà et ça c'est
intéressant de même que c'est
intéressant par exemple des expériences
il y en a eu dans le 05 mais je pense
ailleurs j'ai pas j'ai pas en tête tout
mais des ingénieurs comme ça de
proximité qui s'organisent parce que bon
nous on a conseillé particulier les
Adils aussi etc un moment donné on
réfléchit on se dit mais non c'est pas
le particulier qui va tourner et qui va
aller voir tout le monde on se met tous
autour de la table et on reçoit le
particulier et donc quand on signe comme
ça ensemble des chartes et qu'on
s'aperçoit que ben voilà localement là
ça crée un peu de des initiatives qui
sont je trouve hyper
comment dire vertueuse en sens là donc
et du coup d'ailleurs c'est des choses
qui continuent mais c'est vrai quand
même temps
à la faveur aussi de se rapprochement on
s'est rendu compte qu'on avait un peu le
même point de vue sur la disparition des
espaces eue et le passage au programme
ça c'est que finalement les services
publics historiques de la rénovation
énergétique comme les allées etc on n'a
pas forcément retrouvé notre compte sur
l'organisation autour du programme ça
c'est il n'y a pas eu de moyens mis
alors qu'on aurait pu s'appuyer
davantage sur ces structures là qui en
fait créent du marché aussi pour les
architectes c'est quand même aussi ça et
ben là par contre c'est voilà c'est ça
c'est pas passé comme ça et ça ça reste
quand même une difficulté un petit peu
pour nous enfin un peu beaucoup même
dire que le service public historique de
la rénovation énergétique finalement ne
bénéficie pas de façon claire d'une d'un
accroissement des moyens
pour rendre ce qui est attendu
finalement de ce qu'on nomme quand même
le service public aujourd'hui
en tout cas moi je vous remercie pour
pour ces échanges on doit partir mais
monsieur le rapporteur je vous laisse en
otage
en tout cas merci beaucoup et puis
n'hésitez pas à nous faire remonter des
des explications ou des informations sur
les points que nous n'aurions pas évoqué
merci
merci enfin moi que vous ayez encore des
choses à ajouter mais
je voulais juste si c'est pour juste
compléter ce que ce qui vient de dire
par tout à l'heure sur les
latermographies c'est juste pour dire
que ça va vraiment dans le sens de ce
que je dis tout à l'heure sur la
recherche parce que la constitution de
données fiable sur l'état du bâti reste
aujourd'hui problématique on a fait un
programme de recherche avec l'école de
Marseille l'école de Normandie pour
essayer avec l'ADEME etc de constituer
une méthodologie de travail mais on ne
dispose pas d'outils mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des données qui
sont existantes au cadastre dans les
termographies dans les si j'ai des
villes etc tous les permis maintenant
numérique etc et à mon avis pour mener
ces politiques publiques il faut
compiler l'ensemble de ces données
puisqu'on sait le faire enfin
techniquement c'est faisable et disposer
de que les collectivités locales ou
l'état puisse disposer de ces données
avec les dates de construction les
techniques de construction etc et là on
pourra effectivement cibler les secteurs
les plus prioritaires les uns après les
autres en connaissant les méthodes de
construction qui ont été employées
dans ce patrimoine là et donc du coup le
panel de solutions à inventer à innover
et les acteurs qu'il faut mobiliser les
filières etc
oui ce que je voulais moi préciser
c'était sur le sujet de l'accompagnateur
rénov parce que je pense que il y a eu
une confusion non
ce que nous préconisons aujourd'hui
c'est que cet accompagnateur rénove
n'est pas un statut d'un
parce que nous pensons que ce travail
qu'il a amené les conseils qu'il a donné
c'est du travail de diagnostic et pour
faire un travail de diagnostic on a déjà
commencé à faire de la maîtrise d'oeuvre
donc il s'agit pas d'avoir un amo d'un
côté et le maître d'oeuvre de l'autre
mais de dire que finalement c'est un
travail d'accompagnement qui doit être
fait paramètres d'oeuvre donc c'était
une différence que je voulais signaler
par rapport à ce que
Madame charolais
poser comme problème parce que je
comprends très bien que à partir de
moment où on a un mot c'est bien qu'on
soit indépendant mais là c'est carrément
de remplacer la MO par le maître
d'oeuvre qui dès le départ
dans vous vous souhaitez plus de
précisions peut-être
au fait la précision c'est que celui qui
fait le diagnostic il puisse aussi aider
à choisir l'entreprise et à réceptionner
vérifier que le travail est bien fait et
que l'accompagnateur Renov ça serait
bien qu'il puisse faire tout ça et
attention aussi au prix d'argent public
qu'on met là-dessus parce que ce qui est
annoncé aujourd'hui va être
pas suffisamment rémunérateur pour qu'on
trouve des gens qui veillent bien le
faire voilà
on est sur une possibilité de
compétences assez large quoi donc
forcément en termes de
de
la fois financièrement et voilà je suis
pas sûr que du coup les architectes
aillent beaucoup sur ce créneau là quoi
enfin
oui ça va être un métier spécifique qui
va se monter
je pense que du coup je comprends ce que
vous vouliez dire
maintenant mais
non mais il faut faire attention parce
que c'est vrai qu'on peut avoir des
professionnels qui s'engouffrent
peut-être pour 150 euros bah voilà quoi
enfin encore une fois je veux dire c'est
on a les moyens d'éviter ça on peut
anticiper ça aujourd'hui quand même et
voilà on a un tel chantier enfin il y a
du retard là dessus bah faut le payer à
un moment donné
alors
vraiment il signalétique autour de ça et
on a interrogé à l'administration en
disant mais est-ce qu'on peut garder le
logo ah bah non maintenant vous pouvez
systématiquement l'onglet ce n'est plus
engagés pour faire c'est France rénov et
du coup ça renvoie à la à la fois la
pérennité du dispositif et la lisibilité
du dispositifs pour les particuliers
parce que le même nom s'y perd entre la
bonne trans
ition énergétique
les prix des plateformes territoriales
de la rénovation énergétique
à parler tout à l'heure des audits
réglementaires de l'audiée de
réglementaire réprimer rénoble il y a
l'audit ça également on s'y perd donc il
y a vraiment une vraiment je crois que
c'est assez trivial de le dire de le
rappeler
[Musique]
itifs
agence d'architecture les artisans etc
c'est pas des sociétés avec 50 salariés
donc celui qui va investir en formation
il faut qu'ils disent que c'est rentable
pendant un certain temps et là
aujourd'hui sur pas mal d'objets comme
ça autour de la Réno il se dit bah c'est
quoi la durée de vie de ma formation
j'en sais rien parce que peut-être que
ça va changer dans deux ans donc là il y
a un petit curseur à mettre
je sais pas si ça vous rassure c'est à
peu près une anime je pense que toutes
les auditions qu'on a pu avoir sur le
fait que on est des dispositifs qui
s'empilent et que ça manque de à la fois
de lisibilité de clarté etc je pense que
oui ça ça fait partie et comment alors
je sors un peu du cadre là mais vous
êtes sénateur comment vous explique ça
parce que c'est c'est le cas pour
beaucoup de sujets
[Rires]
on va oui on va on va peut-être arrêter
là enfin on peut continuer à discuter
mais
en tout cas merci merci beaucoup et puis
merci si vous avez des éléments
complémentaires n'hésitez pas à les
transmettre en tout cas sur les
différentes questions et des papiers je
peux vous envoyer également par oui oui
enfin très bien ouais merci